and on it goes my grandmaster
endless moths from
Bangladesh, let's
see who that is so
many grandmasters shouldn't
have
such double remote shadowing
and then for good it doesn't do much
for the development but of course white does
n't have fine contact,
so to speak, and you can't really do it
exploit
so the question is now what about
a structure with E5 do you want to have the
four games and then here the
weakened field
yes well I still don't want
to allow that
I didn't really count on that
well well I'll take the pace with
me I know  also not exactly where he
wants to go to A5
actually looks like a strange
field
maybe just wants to go
back but
after five
it is of course a bit strange there
but well I think I have to
decide on development first
and then try to somehow prove it at the end
that he is in a bad
position here so I could theoretically take A4
but he should get the part
back relatively quickly
we six bishops the seven and so
on well I
think first of all
put out a piece I can be wrong so he
would certainly like to move B5
I think  I have to
counter it in the center it still takes
a bit until he somehow
gets to reasonable squares
general idea would be nicer now Q3 and
then maybe F4F in de5
ah well I did
n't have that in mind of course
if I did  Now bishop C3 games could
do B4 then I would really
have to take it out, which
of course you don’t like to do,
but a queenside would then be
completely isolated,
good at level C1
allow
and hope that the loss of the
black forest runs is almost not that
dramatic
can of course be terrible because
if he comes after the four
even three I have not seen at all
okay
is always good for a surprise that is not implausible opens
the position after all
I am the  undecided how to
place the pieces correctly
think first of all centralizing is not
wrong
bishop has three maybe if he then
plays FI bishop wins the seven material
he certainly doesn’t want me to look at
the pawn time of the week he
has C3
well i had that at the time  not
bad
I hope
that B2 is also possible
and that would be really a bit
uncomfortable I would probably have to
play the queen B1
overall a bit shaky looking
position
that you can hear very dangerous
the econalia even if he
can sacrifice a knight somewhere here then
it is extremely  dangerous
so
good here you have to survive the next few
moves then it should be ok
so the white-wine bishop swaps for
example
and another difficult piece swap
maybe that lasts halfway he luckily is
n’t particularly fast either
wow
that’s okay right away
I can with that  but don't take but
it's all so awful and
I would take the ladies has he runner
A4
okay
I didn't see either oh you
shame
probably I'd better take
my break right away well
it makes me worried runner A4
that's all more than dangerous
yes there  Of course I
played horribly tactically but
of course he still performed imaginatively and
I didn't see him so
the only chance is now oh god
he covered it up too
maybe
my life is
n't the slightest counterplay here
what you can achieve
yes not lost  Of
course it was horrible to do that, yes it
kind of starts here,
I think, because
a good thing can also be that it
's already bad anyway, of course, but of
course I didn't expect EF
and then automatically pulled D1 around it
and that's of course now
here has to be  I'll probably
continue right now
and then some circumstances it's
maybe not that terrible
but
hard to say but somehow did well